another day another direct connection
between Trump and the Kremlin visa via
the 2016 election this time it has to do
with that Russian lawyer Natalia vessel
and that's kaya also a story that did
not get the attention it deserved
yesterday because of Donald Trump's
bogus fake crisis immigration border
wall address to the nation
so let's reset remember that Trump Tower
meeting which at first supposedly didn't
happen then it happened but it was all
about adoptions then it happened and it
was about dirt on Hillary but they
didn't get the dirt and there was no
follow-up then we found out there was
follow-up but Trump knew nothing about
the meeting and most recently we heard
allegations that actually Trump did know
about the meeting all along before
during and after when it took place so
the news is all about Natalia Vessel
Mnet's kaya she is the Russian lawyer
who was part of that meeting sort of the
key player in that meeting she has now
been charged in a separate case not for
her involvement in that meeting she has
been charged because of a not not for
meeting with the Trump family members
and Kushner and whoever else offering
dirt on Hillary she was charged for an
unrelated case because of her
involvement with individuals tied to the
Kremlin and what's relevant about this
is that the charges detail how she has
connections to the Russian Kremlin and
indeed they are very close connections
that's another defense that we heard
from deniers many times which was okay
she's a Russian lawyer
she offered dirt on Hillary she wasn't
tied to Vladimir Putin or the Kremlin
are functioning in any way that could be
associated with being any kind of
official capacity
well she's now been charged federally in
the state of New York for trying to
thwart an earlier Justice Department
investigation into money laundering that
involved an influential Russian
businessman and his investment firm and
what we learned from those filings is
that vessel it's kaya is tied to a
company called prevas on holdings the
owner of prevas own holdings is dennis
katsu and vessel Mnet's kaya's
involvement was specifically working
with senior russian
prosecutors to draft misleading
documents relating to the case
she's now believed to be back in Russia
of course this again raises the question
of who was she representing when she met
with the Trump campaign with Trump jr.
and Kushner and everybody else who was
in the room who was she
representing when she said I've got dirt
on Hillary that can help you defeat her
at this point it is impossible to
believe that she was merely a private
lawyer you would have to be willfully
ignorant or deliberately blind to not
believe that she was representing
someone and there's another really
important element to this a lot of the
work that Natalia vessel Matz kaya was
doing was drafting documents for cases
related to money laundering of Russian
money through New York City real estate
that just so happens to be exactly what
we suspect Donald Trump has been helping
Russians do for decades
my guess Pat is that Muller is all over
this and that if there are connections
between this and Trump or his campaign
that they will eventually be
incorporated into Moeller's
investigation which as I told you has
now been extended by potentially up to
six months but yet another one of those
boxes being checked yet another one of
the defense's we heard months ago
debunked and shown to be completely
baseless and even if it doesn't relate
directly to the Trump Russia scandal it
still hurts Natalia vessel nakaya's
credibility it's hard to believe that
she is on her own time out there
committing crimes money laundering all
these other financial crimes and yet
when she was working with or at least
speaking to members of the Trump
campaign she put that life of crime
aside and just wanted to do with
everything straight forward play by the
book it doesn't make sense it's just not
a believable narrative big picture no
question about it now will she ever will
there be consequences for Natalia vessel
that's kaya we don't know again
reportedly she's back in Russia Russia
not surprisingly does not extradite to
the United States of America
so we will see what ultimately happens
but it is yet another baby step closer
to yes this is a Kremlin tied person who
was formally offering things of value to
Donald Trump detrimental to his opponent
once again the lies that we were told by
the trumpets defenders crumbling every
single day